[Music]
[Music]
i see the crystal raindrops fall
and the beauty of it all is when the
moon comes shining through
[Music]
to make those cobwebs in my mind when i
think of you sometimes and i want to
spend it with you
just the two of us
we can
[Music]
you and i
[Music]
we are together you and i oh how quickly
the time flies i wish nothing would
the change of us
we can make it if we try just the two of
us
[Music]
just the three of us
we can make it if we try just the three
of us
you you and i
cause the three of us
the three of us
that's right just the three of us
we can make it if we try yes the three
of us
here's to hotel transylvania
i think johnny looks way better as a
monster yeah there's a good-looking guy
in there oh and the green really brings
out his eyes hey it's drak going to find
crystal to fix rey to turn us back to
normal
don't tell mavis yeah drak always does
this i hate getting caught between him
and mavis what should i write back how
about no we're not covering for you
anymore yeah now that you're human you
can't do nothing about it go do your own
dirty work for a change buster okay got
it send say hey why you actually sent
this oh man we're in trouble now
nah i just sent him a gift
[Music]
you ready for your big speech honey
fangs yes i think so but ah
johnny is giving me the greatest
headache of my entire existence right
now like a giant wooden stake right
through my brain oh you know johnny he
just gets a little carried away yes
exactly and ruins everything that's the
problem well you're gonna have to get
used to things being done a little
differently around here when you retire
you retire
you retire
retire
not so loud maybe supersonic healing why
would she be listening don't be so
paranoid yes i i'm sure you're right i
just
i don't want anything else to go wrong
everything has to be perfect when i
finally give the hotel
to mavis
what and johnny yes and johnny oh it is
a big step i know how much this hotel
means to you
ah yes but it is time to let go
and start a new chapter together well
you are just all sorts of wonderful
aren't you well it's not for nothing
that they call me count wonderful oh
do they
and also dark prince of lovely news
lord of smoochie times
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
morning tinkles
oh
no tinkers i can't play with you i'm too
busy
i said no
no
go away
a little privacy
tinkles i swear
bad tinkles
no
no no
don't you have anyone else to play with
wait a second that's it
oh tinkles
i have a little surprise for you
[Music]
oh
don't worry what we need
is a monster dog
like
pub
[Music]
say hello
[Music]
come on he's not that weird
um
okay he's weird what about swampy
[Music]
next diablo
next
spike
whatever this thing is
next
what the last one oh boy this had better
work
oh tinkles
great news i found you the perfect
monster pet to play with say hello to
your new best friend
sand
[Music]
dog
sit here
[Music]
[Music]
great now who are you going to play with
hmm
oh
oh
[Music]
on january 14th family movie night is
getting revamped only on prime video
for centuries no human has had the power
to become a monster
until now
but is this safe though let's find out
[Music]
is everything okay down here hey drac
what's up oops
what's going on i used van helsing's
transforming ring
you're human drag dad
oh no i have a total dad bod
um what is going on
[Music]
[Music]
who are those guys it's me uncle griffin
you don't recognize me i've literally
never seen you before
there is a place deep in the amazon only
there can the transformations be
reversed time to go
stereo
if we don't fix you guys soon you'll be
like this forever
being a human is the worst
quito
hotel transylvania transfer mania
boy that was fun
ready pg coming january 14th only on
prime video
[Music]
you